et on a donc appris hier que la Cour de
Justice de la République avait relaxé le
garde des saau Éric dupmetti qui était
en procès pour prise illégale d'intérêt
est-ce que pour vous c'est une décision
politique non je crois pas je crois que
la justice s'est prononcée et que notre
rôle de parlementaire n'est pas de
critiquer ou de commenter une décision
de justice en revanche il faut le dire
c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle pour
les Français parce que on va continuer à
supporter monsieur Dupont Moretti comme
ministre de la Justice or c'est un
ministre terrifiant terrifiant par son
bilan qui est terrible he je le rappelle
pas assez place de prison et
pratiquement aucune place de prison
créée depuis qu'il est en poste des
peines non appliqué c'est le Ministre
des voyou contre le contre les zonet
gens et puis c'est surtout le ministre
qui déteste la démocratie qui insulte le
premier parti d'opposition le
rassemblement national c'est une espèce
d'incongruité démocratique et dont on
aurait été très heureux excusez-moi les
termes de se débarrasser au gouvernement
pour que en frein les Français puissent
être protégés dans leur quotidien et
fent et qu'on arrête en France la
politique sa l'incongruité ou
l'incompétence n'est pas encore un délit
pénal mais c'est un délit politique
presque alors c'est pas encore r du
point de vue de la loi est-ce que vous
entendez cette critique qui est faite à
la Cour de Justice de la République d'ê
une justice de l'entre soit une justice
exceptionnelle on l'entend et c'est vrai
qu'il y a probablement des choses à
améliorer en revanche dire que les
ministres sont sujet au droit commun
pose une autre question celle du pouvoir
des juges c'est-à-dire que si certains
juges veulent se faire un ministre alors
il pourrait le faire donc je pense qu'il
faut une solution par culre c'est ce qui
a été trouvé avec la Cour de Justice de
la République on peut maintenant la
réformer on peut
probablement travailler mais mais pas la
supprimer peut-être un peu plus de
transparence peut-être un peu plus
d'écoute des des parties prenantes et de
ceux qui ont porté plainte tout cela
doit être revu probablement mais je
pense que le vrai problème que pose
cette question n n'est pas celui-là
c'est l'attitude de Monsieur Dupont
morétique et quelqu'un clairement de de
violent dans ses actes et dans ses
propos et qui s'est mis à dos une partie
des magistrat une partie de l'opinion
française et la moitié de l'Assemblée
nationale ça pose quand même question
pour exercer son mandat un pe vous
parlez de vous un peu moins de la moitié
du coup on va revenir sur sur les propos
d'éc duorti vous avez une dernière
question Julien avant de revenir
là-dessus oui parce que é dorti vous
l'avez vous l'avez
dit est intervenu d'une façon assez
véhéante au Hurière c'est votre mot au
sein de l'hémicycle vous avvez Marine Le
Pen avait promis de déposer une plainte
est-ce que c'est le cas je sais pas si
c'est fait en tout cas nous sommes à
l'étude et ce sera fait évidemment parce
que nous nallons pas nous laisser nous
insulter mais au-delà de nous nous
n'allons pas laisser ce ministre
insulter 13 million d'électeurs de
Marine Le Pen juste sur quelle be pénale
la pete parce que comme le dit Julien
l'insulte c'est pas répréhensible par la
loi si quand même on n pas le droit
d'insulter publiquement on n pas le
droit de
traiter
ser vais permettre de terminer quand
même si vous voulez on a un ministre qui
ne parle pas qui éucte on a un ministre
qui ne répond pas aux questions mais qui
vomit sa haine c'est quand même un vrai
problème la question que lui a lui a
posé la députée du rassemblement
national était qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
qu'il n'y ait plus de petit Thomas
demain qui soit tué à coup de couteau
par des voyou et sa réponse a été une
diatrip contre le rassemblement national
il a montré là deux choses d'abord son
incapacité à supporter la contradiction
et deuxièmement son incompétence ça veut
dire qu'il n'a rien à proposer il est
clairement le ministre des racailles
celui qui défend ce qui nous attaque et
le ministre mais vous êtes les premiers
à défendre la liberté d'expression
notamment dans l'émicycle parlementaire
sur quoi vous allez l'attaquer écoutez
on peut convaincre on peut on peut
débattre insulter c'est autre chose je
crois que ce ministre a Moné là a montré
là les limites c'estes limites
républiicaines et ses limites de
compétences nous l'attaquerons parce que
nous ne supportons plus que des millions
d'électeurs soient insultés par des
incompét